so the daily mail uh has this says two
girls
ages 13 and 15 who were charged with the
murder and carjacking of a pakistani
immigrant killed last month
while working at his job delivering food
in washington dc
uh have reportedly reached a plea
agreement with prosecutors
now you remember this um
this case talked about it a few days ago
uh
maybe maybe if you didn't watch the show
or you you know you weren't
if you weren't paying attention to
conservative media that day you may not
have heard of it because
the you know the mainstream media was
certainly happy to move on and not talk
much about it but
it's on video these girls they carjacked
this pakistani immigrant muhammad anwar
66 years old
he was trying to do his job delivering
food for ubereats you know
and they tried to steal his car they had
a taser and he attempted to stop them
from stealing his car because this is
his livelihood he needs his car
in order to support himself and and his
family
and they drive off with him hanging out
of the car
they flip the car send him hurdling he
dies on the pavement
bleeding uh and then and then they're
rescued from the car by some
national guardsmen who are standing
there and nobody has any concern for
muhammad anwar who's just
laying there bleeding dead or dying
no one even checks on him and the girls
the only thing they're worried about is
their phone
they're like stepping around the dead
man saying i need my phone i need my
phone
so that's the case if you didn't hear
about it well on monday
the teens reportedly reached the plea
deal with prosecutors that would ensure
um that they will not be held past the
age of 21
nor be placed in a prison facility
so they carjacked a man and murdered him
and they're not going to prison
according to this they're not going to
spend a day in prison
and they'll be totally free to go by the
age of 21
which means in for the one girl in the
by in six years
if she's getting any sentence at all you
know it's and it's not gonna be prison
it's six years
now you have to ask you know this this
girl
who murdered a man at 15
and uh and cared so little for his life
that the only thing she was worried
about was
her phone afterwards
do you think like six years from now
after spending six years in whatever the
juvenile detention
system or wherever she is going you
think she's gonna be magically a better
person and less of a danger to society
right now she is a murdering sociopath
who does not value human life at all
so you add six years on top of that
going through the juvenile you know
system um and after she's already been
getting given the message from the court
system that what she did wasn't all that
bad
i mean it was bad but not that bad
you think those factors are going to
make her a better person
less of a danger
you know with this per with this person
gets out of jail are you going to feel
would you feel comfortable around her
would you let her babysit your kids
no i don't think so now we because we
all this is the way it's going to we all
know
how it's going to go because it's gone
this way a million times so we all know
this story
and the story is um she gets the slap on
the wrist from the court system
they release her uh back after after she
does her
you know pays pays a whatever penalty
whatever symbolic penalty
and she's released back into society and
you know a couple months later a couple
of years later
she will either be dead or she'll have
killed someone or both
and if she's not dead she'll be back
she'll end up back in prison in this
time
for you know 10 15 years and then we'll
release her again and we'll do this all
over again
while she continues to be nothing but a
danger to
and a strain on society
and all for what now the other question
we have to ask ourselves
is um if in this case these girls these
were uh
two teenage black girls
you know let's just ask ourselves if
this was uh especially in dc of all
places
if this was if we had a video of a 15
year old
white male teenager carjacking a
pakistani immigrant and killing him
and then getting out of the car and the
only thing is worried about his phone is
his phone do you think he's going to get
this deal you think that's going to
happen especially in dc we all know no
that's not going to happen
so this is an example of privilege but
it's not white male privilege that's for
sure
and i think you know their race
certainly helps them in this case
but gender is probably the the most
salient factor here
because the fact is that women there are
there's a lot of
ingrained privilege for women in our
culture today
and nowhere is that more apparent than
in the court system
in fact here's an article this i think
is uh relevant here's an article from
mission from the michigan law website
and it says i'm talking about a recent
uh research paper that was done
it says if you're a criminal defendant
it may help a lot to be a woman
at least that's what professor sanja
starr's research on federal criminal
cases suggests
professor starr's recent paper quote
estimating gender disparities in federal
criminal cases looks closely at a large
data set of federal cases
and reveals some significant findings
listen to this
after controlling for the arrest offense
criminal history and other prior
characteristics
quote men receive 63 longer sentences on
average than women do
and women are twice as likely to avoid
incarceration if convicted
this gender gap the gender gap is about
six times as large as the racial
disparity that professor starr found
in another recent paper now we hear a
lot about the racial disparity in the
court system
the gender disparity is much more
significant
and we don't hear anything about it now
keep in mind again because
in one one of the things if ever you
bring this up
and you bring up the fact that women are
much more likely to get a lenient
sentence which is true
the immediate response will be yeah well
women commit
less violent crime and all that no this
is after controlling for
the type of crime uh criminal history
all of that
so you take a man and a woman at least
in federal court
and uh they're identical
in what they've done in their criminal
history only thing that's different
is their sex the woman's gonna get a
lesser penalty
significantly lesser penalty
so this is a case here this is um what's
happening with these girls i would call
this
it's a couple of levels of privilege
here as they're
as they get to cash in their victim
points
which which literally amounts to a get
out of jail free card in this case
or at least get out of prison free
because they're not going to prison
but of all the privilege their female
privilege i think is the most uh
significant here well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content